welcome back to new rock stars i'm eric
boss and the mandalorian just dropped on
us the
ex-jedi at a time ahsoka tano played in
live action by rosario dawson
one of the most important characters to
the star wars universe she appeared in
clone wars a show that chronologically
already jumps around a lot her own
novel her older self crossing over years
later in rebels
then cambodian as a ghost voice in the
rise of skywalker and then her younger
self appearing again
in the clone wars final season on disney
plus earlier this year and now
an older version again in live action on
the mandalorian yeah she is all over the
place she's kind of like the kid sister
of a drunk time traveler
wait how old are you now oh dear god
what is jar jar doing here
in this dave bologna era of star wars
ahsoka's story
really is the story of star wars with
her narrative redeeming the prequel
trilogy in many fans eyes
and now looking ahead to the post return
of the jedi part of the timeline
her hunt for thrawn possibly redeeming
the sequel trilogy as well
but to make this even more confusing
after ahsoka's recent return dave
baloney suggested that rebels finale
flash forward
might not have been even when we thought
it was come on cowboy
don't worry i got you covered i am gonna
break down who ahsoka tano is her full
chronological timeline how
she got from where we saw her in clone
wars two rebels to where she is now in
the mandalorian
and how she could end up as a ghost
voice in rey's concussed head okay
ahsoka was born in the year 36 bby which
by the way was five years
after the birth year of anakin skywalker
and the birth year of grogu
they were both born in 41 bby yes ahsoka
is five years younger than
the child grogu but i guess doesn't have
whatever aging cream he is using maybe
he's born with it or maybe it's the m
count but when ahsoka was three years
old that was 33 bby
she was discovered and recruited to the
jedi cult
order by master plo [ __ ] from there on
she was raised as a young lien in the
jedi temple on coruscant where her
snips were likely bullied by the
upperclassmen five years her senior
grogu i'm kidding they never met but i
guess he could still bully from afar
now we first met ahsoka as the clone
wars were breaking out when she was 14
years old in the year 22 bby
this was months after the first battle
of geonosis in attack of the clones on
christophsis she
meets her new master anakin skywalker
along with her future bff clone trooper
rex now over the next two years she goes
on a ton
of great adventures that we see
throughout clone wars seasons one
through five
she helps anakin rescue jabba the hutt's
son road of the hutt she takes a
teaching gig on mandalore foils a coup
she runs into grievous and dooku asajj
ventress ora singh
saw guerrera she gets to know padme and
gets kind of sick of politics and begins
to think the separatists aren't that
evil she also meets the mandalorian bo
katan
and the death watch on a mission on
carlac the craziest thing to happen
is when ahsoka anakin and obi-wan go to
mortis
an ethereal plane where a future version
of ahsoka
warns her about anakin but is all plot
by the cosmic entity the sun who
represents the dark side of the force he
corrupts
ahsoka via the dagger of mortis which
was rumored by the way to be the
macguffin
in an early draft of episode nine that
ended up not happening but they kept the
dagger i guess
this is all applaud by the sun against
the daughter and the father
ahsoka technically dies here but the
daughter gives up her own life in order
to
resurrect ahsoka it's crazy and awesome
okay
then 20 bby the jedi temple gets bombed
and ahsoka gets falsely accused for it
this is a huge breaking point because
even after her name is cleared she
parts ways with the jedi order as well
as her friend anakin
a departure that shakes even anakin's
own faith in the jedi order and now
retroactively
is part of the reason he's able to part
ways within revenge of the set so after
clone wars ahsoka story was
picked up by her own ahsoka novel and
rebels but chronologically we will move
on next to the clone wars final season
so after
leaving the jedi ahsoka spends some time
with martez sisters and then helps
poketan
retake mandalore from maul in a sick
duel this arc actually coincides with
the events of revenge of the sith and
order 66
which rex is able to avoid thanks to
ahsoka disabling his inhibitor chip
which is why every other clone trooper
turn on the jedi and the clone wars
series concludes with ahsoka
burying her beloved clone troopers
despite them trying to kill her
and an amazing flash forward in which
vader
finds what he thinks is her grave
overhead
a bird circles this is mori
the bird embodiment of the daughter
which we learn more about in ahsoka's
arc and rebels
it won't make sense to you if you just
watch clone wars all the way through
without seeing rebels which is why i
always say watch this stuff and release
order by the way that owl
also showed up in this episode of the
mandalorian as well very cool but uh
before i continue with this i want to
thank
kiwiko for sponsoring this video kiwiko
is defining the future of play by making
it engaging
enriching and seriously fun they create
these super cool hands-on
projects and toys designed to expose
kids to concepts in science
technology engineering art and math and
are a great resource for learning at
home
each monthly crate is designed by
experts and tested by kids
and teaches a new theme through hands-on
learning and fun cubico offers eight
subscription lines each catering to
different age groups and topics
each box comes with all the supplies
needed for that month's project
so no extra runs to the store what
you're looking at here is the tanker
crate
in which we are making an infinity
mirror and it comes with this awesome
tinker zine
little magazine where it talks about the
whole process of making it the
optical light science that goes into how
cool it is
and all the cool stuff you can play with
like perspective because kids mirrors
may seem magical but that magic
is also another word for science i am
loving the process building this i feel
like i'm a child again i just had more
energy and i got satisfaction out of
building things with my hands
i feel like there's a future in
engineering ahead of me look i really
enjoyed working with the crate and it is
really cool that you get to learn about
something different each month kiwiko
is a great option for holiday gifts be
the cool parent or
cool uncle cool aunt and inspire a
lifetime of curiosity and learning for
the curious kid in your life
check out kiwico.com newrockstars4 50
off for your first month of any crate
click the link in the description below
okay so chronologically next is the 2016
ahsoka novel which follows ahsoka's
exile after order 66 going by the name
ashla
on the rural outer rim planet tabesca
and then as a mechanic on the moon
rada where she runs into the crime gang
the black sun and she eventually joins
forces with
bail organa to become a rebel fulcrum
agent
that is where we catch up with her in
star wars rebels where she now carries
two white lightsabers that she got after
fighting an
inquisitor which our former jedi dragged
to the dark side and tasked with hunting
down runaway jedi this and all of rebels
is set
starting and five bby getting closer to
the battle of yavin ahsoka meets the
crew of the ghost including harrison
doula sabine wren
and the young jedi ezra bridger during
this time she runs
into vader and she is shocked to realize
her former master anakin has become the
empire's deadliest enforcer but she has
some nice moments she reunites with rex
she has an awesome rematch with maul and
she fights vader to allow ezra to escape
but she traps herself in with her former
master and then sometime later there is
a
crazy time travel plot in which ezra
ventures into the world between worlds
he witnesses this duel
he helps a soak offend off vader and
they kind of close that loop
okay rebels ends with ezra sacrificing
himself in a battle with ron on lofall
his home
world using the pergal hyperspace whales
to blast
both of them to some unknown destination
but we were told they both survived now
at the moment we don't know where ahsoka
was during the battle of yavin or the
period of the galactic civil war when
the original trilogy takes place
but the rebels epilogue flashes forward
to some point after the galactic civil
war
after the battle of endor and return the
jedi sabine narrates how she stuck
around to protect lothal
in case the empire ever returned but
they didn't ahsoka appears and sabine
realizes ezra was counting on her
to find him and bring him home that we
assume is why ahsoka now
wants to find thrawn in the mandalorians
she is still looking for ezra but sabine
is not with her this episode making us
a little worried about what happened to
sabine the mandalorian is set in 9 aby
which is after when we assumed the
rebels epilogue was maybe that
was four or five aby but then dave
maloney just noticed a curveball in an
interview
about this mandalorian episode he was
asked when that rebels epilogue takes
place
and he said quote that's not necessarily
chronological
when you go back to look at the epilogue
of rebels you don't really know how much
time has passed
so it's possible the story i'm telling
in the mandalorian
actually takes place prior to that
possible i'm saying it's
possible and i'm saying again come on
cowboy felony hasn't confirmed it yet
but
he is suggesting here that the rebels
epilogue could have taken place
not around four or five aby as we
assumed but
after ahsoka's current arc on the
mandalorian sometime
after 9 aby that would mean the ahsoka
we saw in that rebels moment had
already met mando and grogu on corvus
had already defeated thrawn's apprentice
morgan
and her next words to sabine were
probably something like i just found out
where thrawn is
get in [ __ ] that might be why bologna
is being so
coy right now one of these upcoming
mandalorian episodes might follow ahsoka
and sabine on that mission to rescue
ezra from thrawn
actually be sure to watch rogue theory
this week we are gonna dig into how this
ahsoka vs thrawn
cat and mouse game could be its own
spin-off but for now in 9 aby
ahsoka tano is in this state of going
planet to planet trying to
catch up with thrawn in his probable
plan to build his own fleet with morgan
ellsberg check out that video
this interview with filoni and rosario
dawson talked about how ahsoka is
really in kind of this third stage of
being world weary kind of gandalfy
and we can conclude from ahsoka's ghost
voice appearing in rey's mind during the
jedi voices montage in the rise of
skywalker which was set in 35
aby that ahsoka must have died sometime
between the current time in the
mandalorian nine aby
and 35 aby for what it's worth ahsoka
would be
around 71 during the rise of skywalker
not that old but based on those lekku
wrinkles that are already starting to
show at age 45 maybe she's not born with
it
this is all unless ahsoka was like
speaking to rey
from the world between worlds and her
voice echoed through time
to that moment decades in the future
folks it is
possible and that is why you need to
watch all of clone wars and rebels this
[ __ ]
is canon and dave baloney is gonna keep
plugging pieces of it
into the mandalorian to make us do the
homework but it's fun homework i was
that kid in school
support new rockstars by checking out
all the great options on our
official merch store
newrockstarsmerch.com subscribe to this
channel hit that notification bell
follow me on instagram at eavos follow
new rockstars thank you for watching
i have spoken
[Music]
you